good evening and Aloha everyone welcome
to a special edition of Tucker Carlson
tonight I'm Tulsi gabbard standing in
for Tucker
now I'm so grateful to have had the
privilege of wearing the cloth of this
country now for almost 20 years
currently serving as a lieutenant
colonel and civil Affairs officer in the
U.S Army Reserves but my first
deployment was to Iraq in 2005 where I
served in a medical unit in a camp that
was about 40 miles north of Baghdad and
one of the things that struck me when I
first arrived at that camp in 2005 was
this big sign at the main gate that red
is today the day
now I saw that sign almost every day for
the year that I was there a reminder
that any day could be our last and I was
confronted with just how true this was
as I worked in a medical unit every day
experiencing the high human cost of War
and it caused me to reflect what am I
doing with my life am I making the most
of every day that I have to do my best
to be of service to God and to others
now the question on that sign is today
the day is just as relevant to every one
of us now here at home as it was to us
in Iraq so many years ago
I spoke to Tucker recently on my podcast
the Tulsi gabbard show about this most
important topic here's part of our
conversation I do feel good that's
literally what matters I moved toward
death at like pretty high speed and one
of the first things to go is my is my
sight and I can't text without my
glasses I've been feeling that way since
I was very young moving towards Death at
a rapid rate yes yes
and the root of all wisdom is knowing
that you know exactly exactly I feel
like people who are aware of death are
way happier and lighter because they're
not denying you know what's just
biologically intrinsic like you can't
get away from it you know exactly
because if you acknowledge the reality
of death and that it's not just
something like okay I'm gonna set my
clock it's going to come at this time at
this place at this age then you realize
how precious life is right yes and
you're not in control you look at you
know the problems we have in mainstream
media the problems we have within
leaders in just about every sector in
our society they're chasing all the
wrong things whether it's money or power
or attention or you know so-called love
affirmation you know Fame and all of
these things just come down to this
refusal to even take a moment and ask
the all-important question is like what
is the purpose of my life I know right
like what am I chasing I totally agree
how could you miss that
now as we look to the year ahead we're
reminded about what is most important in
life and in death that we find Hope and
inner peace in God's unconditional love
for every one of us and that true
happiness is found in service to God and
to others subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight